what is the
likely scenario here with taiwan because
it does feel like just in the last two
weeks and your books coming out this
week
we have uh
another acute situation in our hands is
it as acute as it feels
uh like could this happen at any moment
yeah it's really really bad scale of one
to ten
uh i think it's like a nine and a half
oh wow the real the reason is is
i mean if you just uh i think part of
uh the challenge is that it's so bad
that a lot of people almost don't even
want to think that it's true or really
happening denial but um i think there is
a lot of denial because the thought of
being at war with china is so
unfathomable but you know winston
churchill wrote in uh the aftermath of
world war ii that
great wars have a tendency of sometimes
happening very suddenly and he obviously
lived through world war one and world
war two so he saw this twice play out in
in his life in his lifespan
and here i mean if you just look at the
facts
you have
one of the biggest military buildups in
the world going on concentrated in one
geographic theater
in the taiwan strait from china 350
ships they are
i mean as you point out they have been
conducting almost daily incursions in
taiwan's airspace
xi jinping is blatantly saying that he
is wants to unify taiwan with with china
he's 68 years old so
uh when we think about when he wants to
do that it's probably going to be in the
next 10 years and the defense minister
of taiwan says that it could be as soon
as 2025.
so
if you kind of take those facts and
think gee if these people are actually
right if xi jinping if we're going to
believe what he says and if we're going
to believe what the taiwanese minister
of defense says that means that we the
united states have less than 24 months
to decide whether or not we're going to
do anything
to
prevent and deter a potential chinese
invasion of taiwan
that is a really unattractive position
to be in
but the a position that's even worse is
not doing anything and then
the choice is the choice that we face is
okay china we wake up one morning and
china's invaded taiwan and then we
either
basically
send our own troops in to throw the
chinese out of taiwan and we're at war
with china or we don't do anything at
all i think if people people that want
peace and that don't want to go to war
with china basically
have two options either we don't do
anything at all and we just accept it or
we prevent the invasion from happening
in the first place and the way to do
that is to deter it i think you know the
old saying of you have to be respected
by your allies and feared by your
enemies is true i don't think that
being inoffensive and unprepared is
going to be our ticket to peace and
safety in the asia pacific and i think
xi jinping is proving that every single
day
yeah and
people seem to underestimate the size of
the
coalition that would oppose china so
china seems very scary
because they have been
had a pretty amazing run the last 20 30
years in building their society
advancing their society but if you just
look at the tonnage of our navies you
know at three and a half million tons
you know we china's 700 million 700
thousand tons
we kind of dwarf them in terms of our
navy correct
um yeah we have a lot of advantages um
and cards that we haven't played yet um
and i think one of the reasons why xi
jinping is scrambling to get a lot of
things done now
is because he sees his window of
opportunity narrowing i mean he knows
that
10 years from now he could be living in
a neighborhood that actually has a much
more unified front against his agenda
because he sees the august deal that was
signed between the us the uk and
australia he sees japan that explain
what that deal is yeah so that deal is
basically a deal where
the united kingdom and the united states
are going to collaborate to help provide
the australians with nuclear submarines
and that's a really big deal because
you know nuclear-powered submarines are
kind of are crown jewels in the national
security apparatus there it's incredibly
sophisticated technology these are big
chess pieces yeah really big chess
pieces and you know most importantly
they sink ships which is what we need to
stop ships from invading taiwan uh and
they're really really hard to to target
because submarines obviously are
protected by bodies of waters around
them and
uh and you know they move around so
they're they're they're not easy to
strike and they can sink a lot of ships
so
and that's exactly what we need in the
taiwan strait
and if you were to build a coalition
here we have the united states australia
in the uk
uk obviously a top five um military uh a
navy in the world
japan's surprisingly large uh uh and
slightly uh eclipses the united kingdoms
so what is japan's position here i know
i've been reading the stories of them
paying their companies to get out of
china to move their factories
japan seems also willing to put
themselves in harm's way here from what
i understand they will engage
in this defense of taiwan you believe
so they haven't uh
said specifically that they will
directly step in
uh to defend taiwan but they're kind of
dancing around that idea increasingly so
you know the um
japanese minister of defense gave an
interview a few days ago basically kind
of tiptoeing or tiptoeing around that
question basically saying you know we're
not directly
um
we're not uh we will not you know
directly step in for the defense of
taiwan but you know here are all a bunch
of things that we're doing and we're
very very concerned the reason that
japan is concerned is obviously because
japan and china are historic adversaries
they do not like each other and but also
they share i mean the japan knows that
if uh
if china takes taiwan tomorrow
i mean the the next shooter drop is
going to be the senkaku islands which
japan views as an integral part of its
sovereign territory which china has been
uh incessantly trying to annex
and so japan also has is one of the 17
countries that has churchill disputes
with china and they don't want to see
china nibble away at their sovereign
territory and they don't want to see
china start to
tamper with uh trade flows in the taiwan
strait which japan relies on japan gets
90 percent of its energy through the
taiwan strait so
for them and you know the last time that
a country cut off japan's power
uh japan went to war so you know
obviously was pearl harbor so
um
uh you know it's i think they are really
really concerned and my hope is that
those concerns materialize really
quickly into much much closer
um uh military
integration in the asia pacific between
japan and the us because that's exactly
what we need to stop china from invading
taiwan
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
with squarespace you know you can blog
and publish content you can promote your
business you can announce upcoming
events or special projects and you can
sell products and services of all kinds
and more no matter what the problem
squarespace is the answer they have
beautiful templates by world-class
designers that's kind of where they got
started and everybody noticing it whoa
look at these beautiful designs but
they've added so much functionality
since that time including powerful
ecommerce functionality and everything
is optimized for mobile right out of the
box it's got built-in seo free and
secure hosting and of course their 24 7
award-winning customer support back in
2020 we decided we create remote demo
day.com for founders to pitch thousands
of angel investors over resume well we
purchased the domain name remote demo
day.com and had the site up and running
within minutes from idea to execution in
just minutes and incredible
functionality so you can grow with them
and it's been a huge success for us so
far i mean we've invested tens of
millions of dollars i kid you not so go
to squarespace.com twist for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use offer code twist to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain and congratulations to the team
for going public on may 19th what an
amazing journey it's been amazing to
watch squarespace grow and become such a
vibrant company and congratulations on
that milestone